Hey,
we're here with Megan Miller and Ryan Parson.
We just got done doing a podcast.
Yes we did.
That's fine.
It was that the first one you've done?
I Dunno.
Yeah,
every time it was more fun.
I feel like I yell too much
like Julie Diaz,
you gotta Yo let it out and then come back to us.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Don't get me wrong.
I feel bad about it too and I'm like,
I don't even realize I'm at your house screaming and yelling.
I like Joey the mayhem experience and accept it.
No worries
ma'am.
Ma'Am.
I'm known mayhem since he was a skinny youngster when he was hanging around with
margin laymen.
That was back in the day
like coach on the ultimate fighter.
I coached just like mark laymen.
Like I was saying the same words that he used to say,
but he's way more monotone and like,
ah,
I'm not bought a town.
What are you talking about?
Like like that.
I have a different style but like realize damn,
I could have went with them so long that I coach just like a bell.
Yeah.
He said Jujitsu wizard.
That guy is,
he's an encyclopedia of Jiu Jitsu information,
man.
It's just be get blazed a bunch of tapes.
It's interesting,
man.
He's got everything categorized and shit and I've talked to him about it.
She just do philosophy pretty organized about it,
you know?
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
he was the only the organized dude.
It was shocked me.
He would have all those tapes all lined up.
Like,
man,
I could never do that.
Like,
you know,
this tape sign up and nowhere in his tape library stuff was,
he was also a duty.
He didn't want to cut weight.
He was like lazy and Shit.
So he would like battle.
Dude.
It's way bigger than him.
Yeah.
It had to be real technical,
but he's just a smart dude.
He's always been a smart dude.
That's a weird world.
Isn't that the world of the coach that's never been a fighter,
you know,
it's my world.
It was so weird.
He was so stressed to compete too.
I remember he was so stressed out.
I was like shocked.
He was like
kind of,
he would be so amped to,
to coach.
It was a for me.
He'd perform good and you had a good,
they're a good career.
Uh,
grappling ghetto.
Yeah.
Mark Lane.
It's a beast,
but it is a,
it's a weird world,
right?
Isn't it?
Being a coach,
Brian on the sabbath,
talk about it bro,
because,
well,
it's not so much because there's enough talented fighters are on.
The guys can get that aspect of stop,
stop,
stop.
May Ham was waking up,
the neighbors and the cops came,
so we had to double back.
Now we're in a different location,
far away from the fuzz.
You know,
Shit gets hairy when you're hanging out with mayhem.
She gets hairy when you're hanging out with a star,
a bully beat down.
The current hosted the ultimate fighter.
I'm not a host bro coach,
I guess you could say.
Well,
yeah,
I shouldn't say the host call cohosting don't they
read one of his coaches?
Most of the ultimate fighter,
but I guess,
yeah,
coaching.
I'm not going,
hey,
welcome to this week's about,
I kind of am though.
Got To admit I kind of gotten crazy.
Did you bring in hot fail?
Could narrow.
Yeah.
We probably have her buddy fight.
Shoot a buck style.
They have books.
They man,
you know,
it's very nice to you.
It's a very nice,
you guys got to kill a camp now on his him and may can sister gym.
So kings off.
How's the mark?
Munoz is jam.
So Vangelis Shogun do their camps.
May Have uh,
Chris Sauce is in skied.
Mark Munoz.
Jake Ellenberger is added.
Dude,
what'd you think about Ellenberger made perfect sense to me.
I felt like,
you know,
like we train the hell out of that kid and he went in there and did his job.
Yeah.
He fucking knew what was going to happen.
He knew what shields is going to try to do.
So yeah.
So he did opposite indeed.
Well thank you guys for coming on the podcast.
It's a pleasure as always.
Thank you Ryan for participating.
It was,
we're really worried you were going to try and hit this out.
It was much more fun,
right?
You won.
You were awesome,
man.
We would've never had that fucking crocodile story if it wasn't
irrational.
Fear of animals could now he's never gone to Florida.
Thank you Mr. Miller.
Thank you Mary Joe Rogan and we're,
we're out.
You know today maybe it'll help if you pick up bags of sand.
Eddie Bravo on the podcast,
we dropped some knowledge,
drop some knowledge about weed.
He had a cure up.
Some haters.
We've talked about this,
unfortunately ed,
he's got some haters online and people make some unfortunate statements and one
of those statements was made about him wanting to being a bad role model because
he says that marijuana enhanced his life and marijuana help does Jujitsu and
marijuana helps us music and his creativity and some would Jujitsu guy who we
both respect an amazing Jujitsu guy,
but unfortunately he's just,
he's got a shitty idea about what weed is.
So we,
I used to be just like you complete.
Oh,
I used to hate potheads.
Then how was the,
I was worse than you until I did some research and found out the truth.
You could find out the truth to come $3 just buy in,
buy some books.
You can go to Barnes and nobles and they have a whole section on weed and it's
not negative stuff.
It's a whole section on the week.
But it's funny because when someone makes a big statement like that and it makes
a big deal at uh,
uh,
you,
you smoking weed and says you're an idiot man,
they,
they do way more harm for the cause of anti week than they do good.
You know,
because he calling you an idiot.
All it does is make them look silly and irrational and then it gives you an
opportunity to defend yourself.
And then when you defend yourself,
fucking facts start flying out and information and emotional testimony where
you're talking about in your praising the,
the positive effect.
It's way more advertisement for weed.
Every time someone steps up and say something shitty about weed,
the backlash is way bigger now than it's ever been before.
The move movement actually needs people like called Credo to call us idiots.
Cause then we bring out the facts and then,
you know,
we,
the people are on the fence about weed.
You know,
a good portion of them when presented with a correct fats,
they'll go,
oh shit,
they'll jump over people way on the other side of the fence.
We're never going to get those guys.
Not right now.
They're too caught in their ways.
That's fine.
I mean,
I used to be there.
I totally understand what their feelings are about drugs fucking up your life
and ruining and becoming a crutch.
I know exactly what you're saying.
You're,
you're absolutely right there.
For some people,
some drugs can become a crutch.
What,
what marijuana is to me and what it is to Eddie is not,
it's a spiritual thing.
It's,
it's,
it's an an theologian.
It's,
it's something that connects you to truth.
It's something that connects you to a higher feeling of understanding a higher
sensitivity.
And,
uh,
I,
I refuse to accept the fact that that's bad for you.
I think if used and harnessed correctly,
it's most certainly good for you.
And that if people learned about how good it is for you,
it can enhance their life,
including cops,
man,
including all these people that think it's bad and they think people should go
to jail for it.
It can enhance your life too,
man.
There's,
there's a lot of shit that people should go to jail for it.
You're right.
There's a lot of drugs that are terrible for you.
You're fucking right.
There's a lot of drugs and if you sell them,
you're a piece of shit and you should be removed from society.
I agree with you.
But pots I,
one of a man needs thrown in there for the all the wrong reasons and if you look
at it correctly,
you realize that this is something that makes people happy and it's nature and
it's put here on earth.
People have had a symbiotic relationship with this plan for 10,000 fucking years
and the only reason we keep talking about it is because we will get thrown in
jail for it.
Even though the state says it's legal,
the feds,
the DEA,
they,
they think they could just come in and just ignore state law and just put people
in jail.
That's why I'm talking about it all the time.
I'm trying to do my part in the legalization process to open people's eyes once
it's totally,
completely legal and everyone's cool with them and I'm not going to really talk
about it no more.
There's really no need.
Everyone's going to know.
It'll be,
it'll be knowledge.
It be something that's coming.
Understood instead of right now it's commonly misunderstood.
That's the end of our marijuana pro program.
Dr 10th Planet J J.
Dot Com bitches represent
you hadn't done the documentary,
but isn't that funny that that works that way that someone sees a shirt,
it's a dope shirt and like this documentary was gonna fucking rule.
Yes.
Cause they see the shirt.
But it's you,
it's you.
It's,
I mean like don't,
don't want to undersell it.
You're the first one,
but you're being a regular human being.
When you said as you go,
you gotta get me one asap.
Like,
I want to wear it on fear factor.
I want to wear it on the podcast.
So we rush it.
We get it.
A couple of sets of you,
a couple sentences like other people that we know that are important to us and
you wear it and it fucking blows up.
Like literally blows up.
Well that's nice that I can do that.
Pretty easy.
So what was going on?
So when you take it,
when you partake,
partake.
Yes,
it's a,
it's apples.
Cabbage.
It's a,
it's a bad,
massively different podcasts.
Yeah,
it's different,
right?
Like it's cause it's,
you know,
well it's also the one,
the only
podcasts or one,
the only ones that I know of where they let you know if they're smoking weed.
Kevin Smith does too.
He smokes weed through his whole posse.
Really?
Dude,
he's the biggest honor I've ever met.
He's constantly what can believe.
That's all he does now.
He smokes weed all day.
He's obsessed.
It's fascinating.
We haven't gone,
first time I came in here though,
you guys were doing the volcano and I did not partake at all,
but I still got high.
We got so lazy with that.
Volcanoes.
Volcanoes do its work and it's just way too easy to roll a joint.
I liked the volcano though.
It's healthier for your body.
I really should go back to.
Yeah,
but I was sitting next to it.
I was sitting next to it.
It does go through way too fast,
but that's not really a problem here in California.
At least we hope it's not.
It's in 45 days.
They're supposed to close all the dispensary's.
My Guy says it's horse shit.
He says he's not going anywhere.
He says they only gave those things to 16 different people and he said,
uh,
you get to Michigan.
What do you mean they did?
The machine just cleared out Michigan,
all of the medical marijuana,
Michigan and closed down all the fucking that stores,
all of them.
That's what I've been.
People on Twitter have been telling us years.
Really?
That's crazy.
Now I'm all there,
have a,
they have a very fresh program.
It's very young.
California is just so deeply,
deeply ingrained.
I doubt that that can happen here.
Like trying to close all the McDonald's,
you know,
would take,
we would find some place we would find the place because all the Mcdonald's you,
but there's one on that corner too.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's really gross,
man.
It's really,
it's one of the grossest things about our government,
the fact that they're continually going after marijuana and it's,
there's no evidence whatsoever that does anything bad and yet to let and
cigarettes as slide rather than the table.
The fucking,
the weeds of death.
These cigarettes are killing 400,000 plus people every year.
And nobody says a word.
They're just sliding on through.
You know,
everyone's sending jackbooted thugs to go raid medical marijuana dispensaries
and take all their profits and take all their pot and make them go to court for
it and never give it back to them and take millions of dollars from them.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that these are,
these are basically thugs for pharmaceutical companies.
So speaking of getting high and look at it,
ridiculous shit.
This is a documentary called Kubrick's odyssey by this guy named Jay Wiener,
who believes that Stanley Kubrick fake the moon landings.
Granted he also believes is an alien base on the moon.
Then he believes that that's the reason why they faked the moon landing since,
cause they didn't want to go to the monk cause there's aliens there.
What's the lesson?
Is your beliefs to yourself until you come to the good one?
Awesome.
Well,
what's
is the theory is interesting,
but what's,
what's fascinating about it is he points to the symbolism in,
um,
uh,
the,
jacket,
the shining,
the symbolism and Stanley Kubrick's version of the shining and how that
symbolism directly relates with along with numbers and all sorts of things that
he changed that directly relate to Apollo,
to the Apollo Moon landings,
including the room,
the crazy room where everything happened is the exact amount of distance between
the earth and the moon.
You know,
and then he changed it from what it is in the book and made it the distance to
the moon,
you know,
so,
and then there's all this symbolism like the boy is wearing that.
And Apollo a rocket sweater in this one particular scene,
like I'm not doing it any justice.
It's very,
very detailed and it also detailed about the way that he believes they faked the
videos of people on the moon but I think called front screen projection,
which was a technique that Kubrick used in 2001 and in this technique is not
perfect,
but it's basically the beginning of green screens.
What they did before they invented green screen and this,
this technique has a telltale like sort of a line between the boundaries of the
real front,
uh,
the real screen or the real stage rather.
And then the screen behind it,
which is an image which tries to make it electric,
it's a vast distance when in reality it's just a wall.
And this telltale line,
he shows it all is a pallet photos.
I mean it's really kind of crazy if you,
if you look at it,
you look at the videos,
look at the photos and you know the stills of the astronauts bouncing around the
moon,
you're like,
that looks exactly like that.
This is,
this is it.
To couple that with the fact that the same background exists in different Apollo
moon landing missions and their background where they're supposed to be miles
away from each other.
They're supposed to be in a completely different place,
but you have to have the same background as the price of discrepancies about
when it comes to the imagery and what he believes.
He believes that people actually went to the boom,
but when they got there,
the problem was there was aliens there and he points to the clementine lunar
orbiter,
which took photographs of uh,
uh,
a crater and this crater had a very distinct like blue dome in it,
you know,
take it on the grant of salt.
But it's interesting just to watch people go deep into the rabbit hole.
You know what I mean?
This guy must suspend a giant chunk of his life trying to prove that Stanley
Kubrick fake the moon landings.
It's pretty interesting,
man.
Might be a hundred percent horseshit.
Interesting.
Here's the whole thing.
I was thinking the whole time he told me that extended qubit fake to the moon
landings don't you think can be pitching so much other fake shit like guys,
let's also fake this and like why would he go to make movies?
Um,
I think what the idea is is that the government accordingly with his hypothesis
is that the government wanted to fake the moon landings.
And what they did was they came to Kubrick,
they explained to him why they want to fake the moon landings and they gave him
access to all sorts of scientific information.
And cubic is a mathematical genius and he was obsessed with space flight and it
was really like really,
really into that shit.
And so what they did was they gave him access to all of NASA's different studies
and NASA is different,
you know,
technology and allowed him to have like basically an unlimited budget to produce
this and to produce 2001 a space odyssey.
So you could do them sort of in conjunction with each other and the technology
that he could use and portraying 2001 he can use it basically the same stuff
and,
and faking the movement headaches and they would help him get him rich and give
them access to information.
And his,
this guy's take on it is the access to information was uh,
the elites of society.
The,
the hidden,
you know,
culture that runs the hidden societies that run our government for real.
And you know,
the,
the privileged few like an eyes wide shut and we know that like was talking to
the skull and bones as long as weird fucking groups.
Somebody Shit heads get into at the Bohemian Grove.
You ever seen that stuff?
We're all these elites from all over the world and me and his son,
they fucking sacrifice in effigy and they worship this mold left the owl God.
Alex Jones has a whole video where he snuck into Bohemian Grove and filmed all
this shit.
It's pretty interesting.
What's all,
what else is interesting is that when he made the movie eyes wide shut,
that was his last movie.
That movie was sort of about a lot of it was about like hidden society.
It's like secret societies shut up.
Yeah.
So he's kind of,
he was a brilliant,
brilliant,
brilliant guy and he was also a brilliant chess player.
And what they think is that he did it was like he hit a lot of things,
symbolism and,
and you know,
in different imagery in,
in the movie to sort of tell a story.
And this guy breaks it down.
Of course.
It's just,
it's hypothesis.
It could be a hundred percent horse shift.
Yeah.
But it's interesting.
So see it or not,
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
Bert Bert,
bert.com leads gentlemen B e r t three times
oculus.
Yeah.
I follow him on Twitter.
Thanks.
Well thank you.
Always good time.
We hugged it out.
Powerful Ra should fear done with doing the podcast.
Good Times as usual.
It was one probably like the 10th time.
No more than that.
You've done it.
How many times you don't know.
I've just done it.
We've done it a hundred and how many of them Brian?
Hiring 40 or 740 something like that,
but there's a few early on to,
or we were just doing on the couch.
Right.
We all like lean back and pretend we're comfortable with and couch sucks.
It's totally cool.
It's just like so much smarter use office chairs when you think about it.
Who sits up straight all day for office?
People going to use office chairs and that'll catch your head is in my room now.
Which saying?
Yeah,
we recycle here.
Death Squad.
It was,
it was blocking my other cousins and such a board or just blocked my like hell,
it's for like a year.
Really?
I just put it in front of the other couch.
And then what'd you do eventually?
He got rid of the old couch.
No,
I moved them to this space for a while now.
Oh,
that's all you had to do?
I haven't been to your place.
Which court?
Okay.
What was I going to to hell?
Relationship.
My leg.
Why not?
What is it?
Arm.
I got you.
I got to vaporizers.
I gotta.
I gotta get that.
Nice.
Give one a charity.
I think I got to donate to the little bit of comedy store.
That's a good move.
As we look at those attachments,
people break those dose and no one will ever donate it.
Then once fucks it,
we'll just give it to it.
They might,
they might.
They might say like,
Oh,
well we're done here.
Let's get another with your San Diego sounded real profit right now they're
closing down all the pawn shops from San Diego.
It scares me.
Well,
San Diego,
Super Republican.
Donald Rumsfeld lives down there.
Apparently this a corona.
There's this,
the city of Corona.
It's like a corona islands,
like the little peninsula.
It's like one of the most wealthy towns in America and Donald,
the middle one of those there.
They don't want to know pot anywhere near San.
It's a lot of Republicans,
San Diego,
a lot of military to really?
Yeah.
Everybody loves Pato.
Even down there.
Especially now when I they do,
of course you do this,
this conservative people down there,
they just don't want it and you know there's a lot of those fucking guys with
their mustache,
my fucking neighborhood.
You know,
they was just progress.
I've get that.
I get when there's a dispensary,
if near a neighborhood and you buy something you want to like go around the
corner and smoke.
I'm like I don't want to smoke or for something.
Somebodies yard.
It's true.
This is the problem.
Yeah.
That is the problem.
The problem is when it's too near residential or can your school,
some people want to argue with that.
I was real close to the drug store to school but also not really that close and
people aren't doing stuff there.
Yeah,
exactly.
And very few people are in a drug store anywhere on Ventura Boulevard.
I shouldn't say that cause they might,
it's probably a lot of people that get their prescriptions and just fucking Jack
right in the parking lot and know failing an oxycontin thing probably.
Actually that's really normal.
Yeah.
They pop those bitches.
Could anywhere material and he's busy street.
It's like,
yeah,
that's fine.
That's totally fine.
Malls should have punch ups.
They should.
Yeah,
those fucks.
Someone's going to make a fortune putting a pot shop in the mall.
Do,
are you going to make a fortunate that someday?
Do you worry about this backlash?
All the shit that's going on right now,
they're trying to close pot stores.
A lot of times it gets,
it gets to be really inflammatory that people send a good closing shops left and
right.
And I'm like,
hold on.
The only news I really heard is they're sending out 16 letters and they're
shutting down.
They're giving those 16 stores 45 days and make no arrests,
45 days shut down.
And only 16 out of the thousands that are,
you know that story when they came to me there was no one left.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But like I don't know exactly why and what they mean when they say not operating
in the state laws.
Yeah.
Well you're,
you have a real good point about people.
I'm reactionary.
There's one where like the end is near or at worst that too,
but also a what you were talking about how they're supposed to be nonprofit.
That's,
none of them are nonprofit out there making crazy cash.
They have employees that you'd like that.
I get that,
but it would change the real change if you know,
Paul was fucking afraid.
Oh,
it'd be the real change.
Or if you only paid enough to my rowing
fruit.
Yeah,
if I was free,
that would be the real change.
It's everybody just had pot and you just gave people things for pot was like
some sort of a weird barter system or you got paid to grow pot just enough so
that you,
you know,
would you be able to get it around?
It's really good to the supermarket.
Why not?
Why not just come by?
But the idea that you could get paid just enough to justify you growing it,
but you couldn't get Bentley money.
Like you know,
that's what you have to get somebody going to run the whole dispensary pay the
more they don't just get just enough to get by.
Well that's part of this whole thing that's like a hundred grand a year.
That's a business.
That's the person that's running it.
Right.
What about the profit for the actual business itself?
How much whatever you want to make with a regular business.
I don't know how much it's a nightmare.
President of Nike made a shit load.
Yeah,
he should.
She started Nike.
Go ahead.
And you make a slippery slope,
right?
Once you give up anything when it's really not for profit,
what's for what purpose anyway,
but the way it's written,
it is I think any medical drug,
it's for profit.
Right?
So like what is this nonprofit?
I guess the idea is to protect the people problem the first place.
Yeah,
but they are there.
Yeah.
But tomatoes aren't like profitable the way marijuana is probably the wrong and
it's not patentable.
And since it's a psychoactive substance,
I think they feel like anything psychoactive they have to control.
You know,
I feel like,
you know,
if they have some things that are psychoactive that they control,
if other ones they don't control it,
I think maybe get a little testy about that shit.
And then I think pharmaceutical companies would get testy about it.
I think they put a lot of pressure on politicians and that's where all the shit
comes from.
It's a direct,
it's not a result of the people.
There's a White House website.
We can uh,
asking,
you know,
what was your question is the most important?
Quit number one by far is why isn't it marijuana legal?
That's number one.
It's like,
quit oppressing me.
You know,
this bothers,
nobody bothers nobody around me.
So like stop,
leave me alone.
I'm not doing anything to anyone.
Yeah,
me knees,
government meanies cut that shit out.
Yo were hip to you.
We know it's done it.
We're all just people stupid.
Get it together because it's something in ice water and stay black.
Duncan Trussell to fisting with flashlights,
Uno jokes.
One of them is going to stuff up as,
but now,
now that's not the proper use of these things.
These are sex tools,
not sex toys.
Yeah,
we've,
we've got rid that today.
It's probably a bit in that sex tools,
not toys,
toys and a purpose.
They just don't do any open up for me.
I'll kill my fleshlight material.
I won't.
All right.
Which one is 10 minutes on the flush letting you do that shit.
What's this one model act?
Exact same video as we did last time you were here.
I gave him a flashlight to what happens?
Women throw them out.
That's what happens.
Yeah.
Flashlights laying around your house.
Chicks fine and they go with Fuck Dunkin.
They need to make it.
They need to make it safe.
Special fleshlight safe with the code and it looks like a golf club.
You know,
it's like something that wouldn't throw out.
You need to put a Paki in its pocket and it's,
he puts Siri in it and then not have it be like a voice to your flesh.
So you talk to your flashlight.
Tell me I'm good.
Oh baby,
I'm sucking your cock.
I bet they will have that.
They'll have like to,
they don't leave an iPhone sleeve for your flashlight.
I can't believe they just put headphones on.
You know,
and you can actually even watch a video too.
You could have it hooked up to an Ipad as well.
So you're watching a porno video on the IPAD.
Do you know they have a Chinese,
um,
Dick Sucking robot.
They came in with a robot.
They call it like a seaman extraction device,
but it's essentially like this tall and feel like a tube and it sucks in your
consciousness.
That's probably horrendously rude.
Ten five feels terrible.
But they have it.
Course.
I'm surprised they don't.
I'm surprised it blow job robotics hasn't isn't like a huge industry.
Well,
the Siri thing is going to change all that.
And the only thing,
I think so everyone wants to fuck Syria like so many of my friends want to fuck.
That's what Brian wants.
Syrian.
It's his voice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Steve Jobs,
I think,
I think the logical thing is to change the voice.
The Steve Jobs,
since he died like one week before Siri was announced or released.
Yeah.
Why does it have to be a robot voice?
Can you adjust the voice that he died the day after it was announced?
Yeah.
The day after he missed.
That was the first speech that he never gave the keynote speech or whatever it
was,
whatever big announcement speech Kim Cook Tim Cook did and then he died.
They have different voices in different countries,
so they have a like an Australian voice and a British voters.
Those.
Yeah,
but I guess they don't work as good like because he doesn't understand your
accent and words like languages,
like Australians,
like say pubs or whatever they say.
Right,
right,
right.
They have a bunch of different shit going on.
Oh,
you're obsessed with that,
huh?
You're obsessed with Siri.
It's fun to play with.
I want to get it.
Hmm.
I want one too,
but you have a droid fucking me,
man.
I'm losing my words now.
What happened?
I love the Troy.
What happens,
how you're telling me it's the most amazing fun of all time and I went around
and I fucking razzed iPhone owners and I'm like the droids batter,
but it sucks,
man.
It's like they did a software update,
so now it's gone back to like an ancient voicemail from months ago.
I just decided to do that random times.
Pandora will turn on at random fucking times and also it reconfigured my address
book so I have problems finding phone numbers.
It was a software up.
They fucked,
fucked everything.
Fuck that software update.
Once a blackberry killed all my numbers.
I lost every number in my fucking phone.
There were all garbled jumble and half of them were missing.
You know,
they're just gone.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
I had to let go back to my computer and start from scratch.
I had a backup.
Yeah,
they're done dude.
They have nothing there.
They have these little stupid devices with buttons on them.
Right.
When the new iPhone comes out,
they are surface drops out or what?
A disaster.
His ass or,
yeah.
And then it's not just the iPhone anymore.
They're good.
That droid bionic now.
Ooh,
I saw what somebody had one of those other shows weekend.
That's a fucking amazing phone.
What does he do in the camera?
Holy Shit Dude.
The camera has so many different options
tomorrow.
New iPhone beat them all works better,
right?
No.
Everything text on its face detection as cropping.
It's got,
it doesn't have that 4.5 inch screen though,
son.
Yeah,
that big ass.
You know why they did a report of why,
you know the iPhone isn't gone to that yet,
is that the screen is a certain size of screen that once it gets too big,
you can't do it one handed anymore.
You have to hold with two hands and that's the size of the iPhone to actually be
the biggest it usually can get for the average person.
So that makes sense.
That totally makes sense.
I think it's also a battery life
issue,
man.
Those,
those droids battery lives are always out of juice.
My droids.
Totally.
I got an iPhone now.
Yeah.
I want to get her horizon and style comedy money.
You've been fucking headline and comedy clubs down,
man.
You're actually working.
Yeah,
it's an awesome dude.
You're out there headlining on the road,
right?
It's you just also launched yourself into a professional comics 10 scally APA.
Thank you.
I love you.
Start off needed one so badly mad.
You needed one.
An agent that you weren't talented.
What kind of car you gotta get?
You gotta get a car?
Yeah,
start with the car for it.
I've seriously thought of that.
I think that,
uh,
I think that when I finally do get that fucking car,
we're going to have a long conversation.
I'll get you that helped me pick one out or something.
I don't know what kind of car when I can't,
I'm not a car guy.
So it's like,
well,
um,
was a mini Cooper too expensive?
Is that was the deal with that?
Like the one that you have for while the lease expired?
Those are good cars though.
Why not just get one of those?
Because they're a,
I've thought about it.
Like I used to love mini coopers and this sounds so weird and maybe,
I'm sorry to say it,
but like I think like a really nice comfortable fucking like car driving through
traffic freaks me out.
Driving through traffic in La makes me think it's the end of the world.
I feel like having nervous breakdowns,
you look at it all these fucking shitty vans and then you feel like you're right
at the first episode of the walking dead.
Like everything's about to fall apart.
So I want some kind of giant comfort bubble.
Like Ford Edge.
Yeah.
If I've got to go,
go rolling through hell,
was that what you have?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Something that's just like makes you forget for a second year or something.
Nice.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Years in five years now,
I don't know.
How am I going to take two?
I'm not going to get into debt for a car as a thing.
I never want to do at least two or $300 a don't want to lease smart.
They're smart.
You know,
brought the money to buy a car right now.
You should at least get your car fixed once you get it fixed so you can drive
it.
They can do that.
You can try everyone really rough.
Does it?
Totally stop it.
They fix cars.
You don't have to throw them away when they break down.
They're all green with Kasi stairs.
Oh,
maybe I'll get it fixed.
Duncan Trussell does not have a car.
Like he doesn't have a car.
I have a car.
I have a fall though.
89 what's important is Duncan trussell's now baller,
he's officially professional comedian all because of this cause this podcast and
his the lavender out cause the internet.
The Internet has embraced.
Thank you.
God bless here and giving him occupation.
They shit.
What is this?
This looks like flashlights.
They must be yours.
Sweet.
Let me just smuggled out with my office.
Right.
Cuddle.
Cuddle them so I can have lucid dream.
I got the last thing.
Is it really more up to them now?
Do you think that your woman's going to have any issue with those?
Cause we have had friends that we give them to them and then Duncan Trussell
their girlfriend throws them away.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't think mine is that kind of girl.
I think she's going to go.
Can you use the butt end of this flashlight for me?
Stick it up your ass.
Well I have to so we got to fill fast bro.
That's like a fist of iron.
That's about it.
I get it.
I get one in a quarter.
Yeah.
So God damn son,
why do you think I'm with anyway?
Because you like big butts and put it in the man hours,
man.
I,
that's all me.
That's all my stretch.
So that's the problem.
And have a stretch problems right out when she has an accident.
Launching out.
How's the new things that's supposed to be good?
The new thing,
the thing,
the movie,
it looks all right looking for a movie tonight.
I just have you seen drive?
Yes.
You like it?
I liked it.
So she has a little bit of a problem with extreme violence.
That's a tough one to watch and mixed company.
Now if I was with my friends,
probably enjoyed it more.
What did I see last night?
I saw the um,
the tower heist with Eddie Murphy.
How was that?
It was okay.
I had pretty next to nothing expectations and I enjoyed the movie.
Like I enjoyed it.
It's Eddie Murphy back to dropping f bombs and being Eddie Murphy and they still
are not playing Ben Stiller.
He playing a little bit different of a role,
which is nice and it's a lot of corporate groups about the corporate guys
fucking do a little more little suckers.
And then it turns into like a family friendly comedy at the end.
But other than that,
it's pretty sweet.
Kevin Pereira joins us from the podcast freshly from one of our best podcasts
I've got to say to do.
We've done two so far and they're both fucking awesome man.
You got such a wide variety of interests and viewpoints and you got a little bit
of crazy conspiracy theorist in you,
but realist along with it.
It's not the,
you're not reaching a healthy dose of a tin foil hat is sometimes a good thing.
Have you ever sat down with Alex Jones?
Have you ever had him on your show?
I,
you know what,
I tweeted out,
I wanted to interview him and I tweeted out one of his articles and,
and he was such a polarizing character that the backlash from tweeting that out
made people not want to listen to the message I was trying to give.
So I'm a little reluctant from that,
but,
but what I have seen from him at times is this so far,
pretty interesting to me.
What about if I had him come on or as a podcast?
I think you would be the perfect counterpoint.
Would you sit in and have us off podcast?
I'd love to.
Alex Jones here.
Okay.
With Kevin Pereira.
Kevin is from g four attack of the show.
Attendees of the show is a new world order device.
What they're doing is softening up the idea.
It's attack gets attack of the show.
We're all friends here.
Uh,
I,
we are owned happily buy in
via Comcast,
so general electric,
they're shooting fucking bombs.
He goes Kennison Anya,
he's amazing.
Happily chat with him.
He's awesome.
We got that with him in Texas.
He came to the fights.
We,
uh,
we had Margaritas during the day with Alex and then we went to the UFC that
night.
I didn't get to hang with them,
but Joey Diaz gave him a pot cookie and put them on the fucking moon.
Oh.
Allegedly.
He actually said on a show the next day that he has smoked pot with me once a
year just to try it out and see if I'm in the decriminalization.
So good.
Good
for him,
man.
It's true.
Once a year I come into town and I get,
we,
we could smoke a little weed.
I love it.
Does it,
does the polarizing nature of his character concern you in terms of aligning
yourself?
No,
I'm it much who I am.
I don't think anybody has any questions,
you know,
I mean anybody who knows me,
they know me from the podcast.
Right.
You're not going to,
I don't think it's confusing.
I think I find a lot of what he says fascinating and I don't buy into all of it,
but I to buy into something of it.
He's got a great video on what we're talking about tonight,
but provoca tourists or,
yeah,
we was talking about um,
the uh,
the um,
protest,
the WTO protests in Seattle and uh,
how it was set up where these military people would come in and it caused
violence and they were wearing like ski masks and Shit.
They were breaking windows,
they were wearing fucking military issue boots and they want up getting,
they want of going into a safe house and then they get a,
they,
the cops negotiate with them and they let them all go.
Yeah,
I mean it's like,
it's so gross.
He documents it in great detail.
There's videos from occupy where,
where people are in the crowd,
they're screaming,
they're trying to rile up the people in the frontline as they're approaching the
riot cops.
The riot cops step aside after telling people you can not go down the street.
And a line of eight of them walks right on through the police line.
Then they close up and not arrested the dudes that walk on by,
but they look like plain clothes protestors.
That's already happened.
It's already happened.
The what is the justification?
How do they sleep at night knowing that they're doing that kind of shit and just
doing that job,
man,
that's like Nazi Germany Shit,
man.
That's like Earl.
Well,
yeah,
and it's,
it's,
it's creepy that you can get an American citizen to trick other American
citizens like that.
But again,
we talked about desensitization.
They don't see,
they don't see Americans.
I don't see you and I potentially,
they see dog.
They see rabid dogs who are uneducated and hippies and x,
y and z.
That's what they see and they're just getting their paycheck.
They're just motherfuckers see were riled up again.
Oh,
this is the time clutching flashlights and health of brain,
so clearly I'm in the right minds or credibility.
Clearly I'm in the riots.
Substantially undermines your credibility.
Anyway.
Follow Kevin on Twitter.
It's p.
Right?
Yeah.
I got to get an easier one than that.
Yeah,
that's hard.
Perera should have it spelled like career,
like Porsche went through days.
Carrera Perrera.
Is it Portuguese?
Yeah.
I can't look it up.
What the guests,
how do you say it in Portuguese you got say it with a mouthful of bread and
angrily then it's Portuguese.
That's only once you get for tie down.
A mouthful of octopus soup is regularly different than Brazilian Portuguese.
Is it a different way of pronouncing things?
I mean,
I think there's,
there's like a region,
regional dialects and whatnot,
but it's still fundamentally the same language.
It just put a little spin on it.
Brazil is so strange,
man.
What a crazy country.
They speak Portuguese in their middle South America,
right?
Everyone around them to speaking Spanish and they speak Portuguese.
Good fighters,
good tankers,
good party.
My friend Kevin Pereira,
folks,
that's it.
Oh,
okay.
What's the meaning of life?
Try and be nice to people.
Avoid eating fat.
Read a good book every now and then.
Get some walking and tried to live together in peace and harmony with people of
all creeds and nations.
Oh my God.
I'm walking in and read a book once in a while.
How?
Say that I won't eat fat.
Did that just give you a chills?
Yes.
[inaudible].